it was 1993 I think or four and I had
gotten a deal at Warner Brothers like an
old-time writing deal where I was
exclusive to Warner's and wrote had an
office there and I lived miles away and
I got a fax and faxes were so incredible
that I didn't have one in my house and I
had one of my office so I was all
excited I'm gonna go through my faxes
that I have a Warner Brothers and one of
my sons with was not in school yet he
was three Martin and put him in my car
we're off to Warner Brothers and he had
just watched Treasure Island fifteen
times and luckily I only had to sit
through it with him seven times so that
was good but he had a pair of plastic
binoculars and he was looking out the
window with a car the whole way like I
don't know how he didn't get seasick and
throw up but every time I I'd say Martin
what are you looking at he say I see
gold because the Treasure Island and all
that stuff and we have crossed the 405
freeway and Martin what are you looking
at I see gold in the hallway and we get
to the parking lot at Warner Brothers I
have my own spot which they haven't put
my name on the footing yet but they're
gonna and I think it took like 1997 when
they finally got my name on the footing
but it's the greatest film studio honor
and pulling into his parking spot
outside his office is the greatest film
director honor Richard Donner and I had
seen it many times in the parking lot
sometimes it is Porsche sometimes in his
small Cadillac you know it was always a
different car but it was one of his
Rolls Royces I think and he's getting
this script out of the back of his trunk
and I'm just thinking Mike got a stick
Donner it's picked on you know it's
unbelievable there he is and my son is
walking next to me with the binoculars
and dick turns around he doesn't see me
he just sees this kid walking with the
binoculars and he goes he almost walks
up into him and he goes hey and my son
looks up at him
and six of what are you looking at my
son says I see goal then dick said
you're goddamn right you do
No and then he looked at me and he said
what do you do and I said I'm a
screenwriter and he said something like
oh I'm very sorry to hear that about you
I hope you get better and three days
later I got a call and four days after
that I was a working predict honor